a really good example of where they
failed was
grenfell tower so for ages the locals
have been saying
this is a death trap this place is a
death trap
and had it been 20 years ago there would
have been local journalists
on that patch covering that story
holding the local council's
feet to the fire and saying this is
dangerous you need to change this and
they might have changed it
it didn't happen because they don't
exist anymore
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster and i'm constantly
kissing
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a journalist and
broadcaster
tom latch and welcome to trigonometry
how you doing i i feel so
overwhelmed by that intro and also given
who you've had in the past slightly
cowed as well you know i mean
the brilliance of peter hitchins and
mike graham
hello mike if you're watching i know
mike mike doesn't watch the show well
mike gave me my break in
uh in radio so mike was the man that got
me onto talk sport for the first time
and i used to pay for a review with him
every week on the overnight
show and then i ended up getting my own
show on talk sport so if you are
watching mike
thanks but it didn't work all right so
if this is [ __ ] you know who to play
but i'll joking aside it's great to have
you on the show tom just tell us a
little bit about for anyone who doesn't
know who you are
what is your background like what's been
your journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here in this chat um
so i've always been into i've always
been good at english i suppose my dad
was a journalist for the bbc for 20
years
and my younger brother is also a
journalist for the bbc currently works
for five live
so there is very much a journalistic
background in our family um and so
i decided i wanted to be a newspaper
journalist when i was about
so i did work experience all that stuff
ended up getting on the
daily mirror graduate training scheme
straight out of university
worked there for three years pissed
everybody off they moved me
and this is why he's on the podcast yeah
they moved me to the people uh which was
like
like the run of the litter you know like
in trinity mirror you've got the daily
mirror the sunday mirror
and then the people and all the wrong
ones works on the people and basically
the daily mirror they said yeah
you know you're a good journalist but
you're right in fact my boss saying
you're a rough diamond
and uh and someone will knock the edges
off you
but basically it wasn't going to be him
and he moved to the people so i went to
the people for a year which was
miserable
um because you know i mean the people
has a proud tradition but i don't think
that prior tradition has been there for
quite
a number of years and i got head hunted
from there right at the end of my
graduate training scheme i'd signed a
contract to be on the people to take
their staff job
and then use the world hunt of me just
just after i'd handed him my contract
and said you want to come and join us on
the features team
and so i had to go back and say that
contract i've just signed
uh can i not uh go through that which
again pissed people off i got put on
guard and leave and then i went and
joined the news of the world where i was
a feature writer and then became tv
editor quite quickly within about a year
and then of course the newspaper shut
and through thrust me out into the world
and i decided at that point i'd try and
become a radio presenter
because i've done some radio and really
enjoyed it i love the thrill of
broadcasting and actually when i started
my career i always thought
i'll do newspapers then radio then tv is
a nice
sort of journey and i worked
on that freelance journalism worked on
the attempt to become a
a radio presenter mike graham gave me
that opportunity
and then a couple years later basically
this is what happens at talksport they
had
they had a big gap and they were like uh
what we're going to just fill it tom do
you want to do it and i was like
absolutely yes so i did the overnight
show for
at the weekends for like two or three
years and thoroughly enjoyed it
uh i think the ratings were among the
highest they've ever been when i left
but it came it became obvious that i
wasn't going anywhere on the top on talk
sport
so i decided to jump before i was pushed
and so
i left a year ago and now i do i have
everything really a bit pr
a bit of a bit of broadcasting just
about to launch my own podcast
on the 90s rave scene if you want to
check it out raw it's called
raw the 90s rave podcast uh if you're
into that there'll be like one person
maybe this listens to this that might be
uh and yeah just do all sorts of bit of
journalism a bit of pr and a bit of
a bit of broadcasting bit of everything
really so you were brought
so you were a tabloid journalist for
very many years i was and even when i
was a freelance journalist i was
generally serving uh tabloid newspapers
because the money
is not really there on broad broadsheets
don't tend to pay for stories in the way
that broad the
the tabloids did so i would yeah i mean
i've been a tabloid
sort of i would say a tablet journalist
tableau staffer for five years
a freelance journalist working in
tabloids for 15. yeah
and when you see tabloid journalists
criticizing tabloid journalism
what is your initial impression do you
think they get a lot of unfair criticism
or do you think it's fair the criticism
that they receive um
i do feel and this is this will make me
annoy someone for my colleagues and i
apologize to them
if if if it does well i i do i i feel
that newspapers are very old-fashioned
i think that when the news the world
shut
um there was a sea
change there was a desire for newspapers
to be
more modern you know you look at just an
example there was calls for such a long
time after that for the for the sun to
drop page three
and it took forever for them to do it
and it was only when they were you know
dragging and kicking kicking and
screaming to do so
and i felt that there was an opportunity
after news the world shot for tabloid
newspapers to modernize to
to seek a younger audience
maybe they just were never going to buy
newspapers i don't know but they focused
on
they sort of retreated and entrenched
into their
ever diminishing aka dying
readership you know and and and i just
felt that
they they became decreasingly less
relevant
and so now obviously online the rise of
online is where you're sitting and you
are seeing those big brands
male the sun the guardian you're still
seeing those big brands
um dominating that market
but i think they probably
started too late they there was no
cohesion in how they did it some didn't
pay all some didn't
and the fact is you can get most your
news for free it you can't put the genie
back in the bottom and make people pay
and i think that's a big problem for
newspapers and online online journalism
doesn't really pay very well they get
kids in uh it's journalism they're
ripping off articles
they're doing so i should point out they
are doing some original journalism the
guardian of course
the sun does quite a lot of original
online journalism
uh the telegraph as well i would say
yeah
yeah there is some original journalism
but there's a lot of journalism and
there's you know the the
the talent the experience has been lost
out of newspapers and therefore the
quality
and the stories that they're delivering
are lower and less good i mean that's an
issue
i think it's more about massive content
and quality of content and do you think
that's mainly a technological
transformation where as you say people
don't want to buy a physical newspaper
they might not
want to buy one for ethical reasons they
might not want to waste the paper a lot
of people
think that way as well you know you
can't get them delivered anymore
yeah well i mean you can get the times
delivered essentially but you can't
generally you can't get there's not many
places that do newspaper delivery
so unless you go to the supermarkets and
actually this you know this is another
another
thing that's just hastening the death of
newspapers is coronavirus
most people would get it when they went
to the supermarket or they went to the
shop of the morning
well coronavis people weren't going to
the supermarket or the shop every
morning they would go once a week when
they needed to because it was
it wasn't essential well therefore
newspapers the newspaper cells just fell
off a cliff over
over coronavirus that plus online they
were doing ad blocking i don't even know
anything about this but basically
um the advertising the advertising
companies
um basically uh have a list of block
words
where if there's a block if there's a
certain block word
they cannot advertise on that page they
can they can you can fine tune it
individually but one of the words was
coronavirus
well so all stories feature coronavirus
even if you're interviewing a celebrity
now
you ask them how their lockdown was
how's coronavirus been for you
so even if it's not you know because i
understand why they might not want to
advertise on a page about
x number of deaths per day i totally
understand that
but to blanket band coronavirus seems
absurd particularly given that it is it
is enveloping everything
and so they lost millions and millions
of pounds so again that means there's
less money to
invest back into journalism um and i
think it's just hastened the the the
probably haste and the death of of
newspapers um
i think newspapers people like having
something to hold a lot of people i've
been speaking to friends they think
they've probably got like
10 20 years but it'll probably be the
bigger brands that exist as newspapers
and then it will go all online but we're
a million miles from
like the mail online monetizes it
they're just about
but not no one else i think the sun
online washes its own face just about
but i don't mean to make huge amounts of
money and you know from the guardian as
we've seen it relies on money from
you know the the scot trusts they sold
um they sold they goes to auto trader
they sold that for
just a couple hundred million pounds
something like that and so all that
money is going but but when you've sell
everything and you haven't got any more
scott trust money you are unable you
have to monetize it and
i think they're doing okay online but
certainly not making huge well the
guardian i mean their section at the
bottom begging people for money is now
bigger than half their articles but
uh but you know i was asking you about
the technological point because i guess
one of the things we've explored quite a
bit on the show is
that what you might describe more
broadly as the kind of decline of the
mainstream media more generally
and the feeling among many people that
the mainstream media don't seem to be
offering the substantive stuff that they
used to
which is where stuff like this comes in
where people actually have the
conversations and that's obviously not a
newspaper thing it's more of a
online the radio all of that stuff tv
a lot of people now feel like the
mainstream media is no longer doing
the job that we think of the mainstream
media as being
there to do do you know what i mean i do
a good example is sport
so the sports coverage was
certainly in the tabloids it would be
all about transfer rumors
well i mean nowadays if you want to
transfer room you get them anywhere you
know
you can get that stuff anywhere like
that all sorts of places are doing it
i don't believe halfway anyway it's all
written it's all sort of the
you know agents who want to get
something out there
you know it's and hardly any of it
hardly anything you read exclusive
transfer wise is like
really a genuine exclusive so what i was
thinking was like why don't they and
why don't they switch to analysis you
know because that's the sort of stuff
you can't get anywhere because you know
you need to be
really in tune with the people who who
know what they're talking about you know
you need to be having those
conversations on a daily basis those
websites that run my kids don't have
those
let them do the transfer crap fine
whatever but it's that sort of in-depth
analysis and which is why you've seen
the athletic
you know be so successful because
actually it focuses on
i mean it could do a good sub editor
because the articles are way too long
but
they do focus on in-depth issues and
explore things
tactical side of things all that stuff
and i just felt why don't they do that
so you know there was an opportunity for
instance in that area to provide
something
that is different and makes them stand
out that they've got the um
the budgets and the capabilities and the
staff to do
and they don't haven't really done it so
that's an example of how they're failing
i think
and it's also do you know i think as
well thomas the fact that people no
longer have faith
in what they're being told by the
mainstream media a lot of people no
longer believe it
yeah i mean there's definitely a a a
trust issue and i think that goes across
the board
where that comes from it's probably
partly to do with their own fault
uh through a series of
i said honestly it's a series of things
isn't it you know phone hacking uh
which erodes you know roads that sort of
trust it's the
um the close links between the police
and the
government and the newspapers which
again erodes that trust it's the
the sourced quotes where you don't know
where they come from and they're not
named and
that erodes the trust and um yeah
there's just there's just a series of
things but you've also got lots of
people like donald trump
and other not necessarily by people
but you know dominic cummings whatever
just telling people that this is you
can't believe this it's fake news when
it isn't
um and i think there's just been a
there's just a sort of series of factors
like a maelstrom of factors that
have led led to this position and it's
partly to do with the newspapers it's
partly their fault
but i wouldn't say it's all their fault
and you don't think part of it is
the fact that what we've got now a lot
of is advocacy journalism like you've
gone to the guardian
you know that they're gonna give you a
very particular outlook
and you know it's not going to be
objective the problem the problem
is though is that neutral journalism is
boring
but no one just wants to read neutral
journalism it's dull like
you know it doesn't interest people
doesn't decide people you know
the thing is when you work in the
tabloids one thing tabloids do
well historically have done well whether
they do so anymore
is it can be debated but the one thing
they did do particularly the daily mail
whether you hate
like it or you hate it well there's
always coach when i do my journalism
training
is um make this story
like me so it's like when you read it
you're like why are they going to live
in a
450 000 pound house in a leafy suburb
you're like
what does that matter it does it's
subconscious it's people going
ah they're just like me so you carry on
reading it
you know i was once told and this is
appalling by the way i was once told on
one of my newspapers
that i was working at um
[Music]
if you ever have a story about uh an
asian
uh lottery winner put their name in the
seventh paragraph
because if you put it in the top
paragraph or the second paragraph
whatever it's gonna be
people won't read it and the majority of
newspaper readers are certainly tabloids
are
white similarly tend to be working class
people
now whether that's true or not i have no
idea i was appalled by the idea that
that they would do this and that it
might be true
but that gives you an idea their writing
going right we need to we need to angle
this story so it appeals to our readers
and that is what tabloids have done
historically very very well and
particularly the mail under paul daker
long time
you know particularly you know when it's
at its pomp
um they did they they frame a story so
it appeals
you know and that's why there's lots of
sexy stuff in tabloids
because whether you like it or you don't
that does appeal to people
it does interest people it gets people
looking at it it gets people reading at
it
uh reading those stories if it's just
plain and bland
and there are people i'm not gonna name
the paper you know there's a particular
paper i can think of
that is run pretty straight and it and
it isn't particularly political
and it's not that interesting to read
yeah so it's it's difficult to strike
that balance where you've got to be
you know as subject or as objective as
possible but you need a little bit of
the flow
also they're owned by people who have
political opinions
yeah you know political views so you
know you look at uh well it just was
slightly weird with the times and the
stunning times because one was remain
and one was
and one was leave which was always weird
which suggests actually that rupert
murdoch's view wasn't as strong
on it as as as it might have as it might
have
we might have believed because we all
know that he you know i think we all
know that rupert murdoch
wanted to leave the eu the sun was very
strong on it
uh the times the sunny times i think was
leave and the times was remain so you
know but you do have these on
these uh owners of these newspapers
pumping money into it you know they're
not doing it because they you know they
might do it partly because they love
journalism that's not the reason why
they're doing it
they're doing it because they want power
influence
they want to make change and so
therefore you have to reflect
what your owner wants sometimes now
sometimes you reflect what you think
that your
your reader wants so the sun was very
much leave because most sun readers
will leave but there are there are
factors that influence
why a paper writes certain things in a
certain way
um that are you know beyond
just its politics well let's pick up on
that actually because that's the thing
i think that i think most people don't
think about which is all of these
broadcasters or most of the broadcasters
other than the bbc
uh radio stations newspapers tabloid
newspapers
they're all owned by somebody and those
people usually own them because they
have very strong
agendas to what extent do you think that
influences the the the kind of the
direction of of the
publication is that they're all
different yeah they're all different but
are there other people like who are just
like you know what i bought this thing
and you now do whatever you want who
does that
who buys us who buys a business and go
do what the [ __ ] you want with it
nobody nobody does that of course i mean
that would be insanity
well probably the owners of west ham
mate i mean ultimately also i mean let's
be honest they'd like to make money off
it but right they're not making a huge
amount of money on these papers anymore
are they yeah so why do they have them
right yeah you know when rupert murdoch
dies what will happen to the sun
i don't think his kids care about
particularly something they're
interested
so what will happen to them no one knows
but it but it's something that you'd
think about
because he's he's he was he 82 something
like that you know he you know he's not
going to be around forever
so what happens then i i honestly i
don't know
but i think that you know that's a very
interesting moment for for newspaper
journalism because he's one of the few
people
who does love newspapers he's in his
blood you know his dad was a was a was a
newspaper journalist in australia and
stuff like that
so um but yeah i mean
to go back to your question no but
some people do do it because they love
journalism because it's important but
they also
use it for influence you know for
lobbying you know all the various
different owners
like to be like to know the prime
minister
you know they like to be seen with all
these people so therefore it's that
and there's many reasons why they would
do it but also they you know they don't
do it to lose money and just allow
someone else to just run it how they
want
but i would say as well actually it's
like i i'm not sure because
rupert murdoch gets probably not an
unfair reputation about how
much he influences newspapers and i
speak to people who work there
i've got very close friends who are very
senior on some of that on some of the
news uk uh papers now i don't think his
influence is as strong as everyone
thinks it is
these days i think he largely allows it
to
to exist he might you know once i mean
he's famously you know you
appears morgan wood wrote in his diaries
was it back in 2006 talks about when he
was the editor of the news of the world
when he was a kid about
being flown out around the world to meet
rupert murdoch to be anointed and then
he would like
often ring up i think there was one
story i said he had a story about
one of the emmerdale stars shagging
someone or something i mean
it was a lame story and he was going to
put it on the front and rupert murdoch
rang up as he would do every saturday
and so what are you going to put on
what are you going to put on the front
page and he said i've got this story and
he was like
i can't remember the exact quote but i
was like i mean that's a joke obviously
isn't it you're not going to do that
he was like yeah i don't think he does
that anymore
and i wonder whether the news the world
what happened with that he probably was
getting a bit
his influence or his desire to be
influential on it was probably
decreasing
and then that sort of that was a big
paper
that went um how much of an influence he
has i don't know but i don't believe
it's as probably as strong as everyone
you know your partner on the street
believes it to be because i could be
wrong by the way you know i mean all of
this is just
from from conversations i've had but
that surprised me
but you know you've got to i got to
believe people who work in that
in that building but you look at the
times and their journalists are fairly
balanced you tend to get someone from
the right whether it's a melanie
phillips and you get
somebody from the left and then you get
somebody from the center and all the
rest of it they tend to be quite
balanced in their outlook which
they do but what i will say is this
person you might be able to
might want to get on the show in the
future it's a guy called mick right he's
uh he's on twitter he's quite a prolific
sort of writer he's quite anti
papers and he does this thing where he
so newspapers always say they want to
appeal to a younger audience so he
adds up the ages of the columnists
and the averages and the average is
usually men
yeah generally white men generally
of you know who are in their late 40s
early 50s
yeah so you say they're balanced but
but they may be balanced in terms of
their politics but they're not balanced
in terms of their
ethnicity in terms of their backgrounds
in terms of their
ages are they and all that is if all
that is impactful upon what they write
of course it is
so do you think they need to be more
balanced if they're going to appeal to a
younger generation i think they've
missed a boat
i mean i don't think newspapers are
going to appeal
to younger people i think they missed
that opportunity and i watched it happen
and i was like
go on you can do it you can do it you
know and they just
missed it as i was watching i'm like
right okay
fine that's that then um i mean online
is a different beast
altogether and actually online
journalism is a fascinating
thing to think about i've never worked
in online journalism so i can't
say how it operates on a day by day
basis
in terms of how they select the stories
and whatever but from what i do know
is i mean i know that they have real
time
they can literally see in real time what
story is doing well and what story is
doing back
and a lot of the stories you'll see will
be based solely around what is trending
that day right so
or that week what's big so you know game
of thrones always massive
anything you can link to game of thrones
online because it comes up in the search
engines it comes up in the you know if
you deal with game of thrones
you know the sun or the whatever game of
thrones stories on the carousel on
google
that's how they do it now what you could
say is with that
you can so sometimes i'll pitch a story
to them and they'll say
it's not going to do anything for us and
you're like but it's a good story and
they're like it's not gonna do anything
for us and you're like
right so what's the judge of what you do
how do you judge what story you use this
clicks
it's clicks so you could say well that
is the pure democratization
of newspapers of media like for ages
we've just been relying on one bloke or
woman but large usually a bloke
uh often white often privately educated
sitting in an office
uh gets his news list they come in they
present in conference they say these the
stories he goes that's the splash
that's the page three that's the page
five uh you know the four five spread
that's the that's the page eight uh um
or the page six or the page eight um
opinion piece
done and you're like what are you basing
that on now you'd hope that they would
do some sort of
you know there's such massive
organizations with such amount of money
in them or
or you know that they would do um
sort of like what would you call them a
group
you know studies where they when they
ask people what what do you like what
are you interested in so you know you've
got a basis but ultimately it comes down
to one person's decision
so have you been getting it wrong the
whole time has this person been getting
it wrong actually this is what people
are interested in oh it's a great story
but it's not what people are interested
in whereas now you know what people are
interested in
it's slightly skewed because a lot you
know some things are shared by facebook
so
therefore who's sharing that i'm not i
mean i'm on facebook but only just
it's my mum it's my you know it's my
auntie
it's not young people anymore they're
the ones that are driving the numbers
so is it democratization so you know
it's it's an interesting sort of
thought or discussion to have about is
it
is it pure journalism actually or or is
it
slightly bastard i don't know it's it
the honest answer is i don't know the
truth
but what i do know is that selecting
things purely on the basis of one
person's view of what is a great story
and the best story of the day
is not necessarily reflecting what the
readers want but the downside with that
the other model which you know i write
for a couple of
opinion opinion pieces for a couple of
papers online
and they talk to me all the time about
oh this article did this well and the
article did this
i suppose the problem with that is uh it
kind of we talked about
echo chambers for last four years
particularly since brexit and trump and
stuff like that
it pushes people i think and that's the
dangers it pushes
people into more and more of the same
thing that they already like and also
if you look at so i don't know what
articles you've written and how they how
well they did but i just they were
[ __ ] amazing
of course right more are you
yeah always you're always on the phone
yeah man he's doing very well at
buzzfeed
i don't think buzzfeed's doing very well
certainly not the news department uh
sorry anyone who's watching you from
buzzfeed you've lost your job
we don't care i know what i do i feel
your pain i've been there and what i
will say is you'll be fine
um but what i would say you know those
articles that you did and they said how
well
or bad they did i don't know if you can
if you if they said as much as this but
i would be i'd highly bet that the ones
that did well were the ones were
incredibly polemic
rather than nuanced so it goes back to
why don't we write things straight it's
[ __ ] boring
no one wants to read it what people want
to read and actually i think it's
unhealthy
for um for public discourse
for starters but also i think it's
unhealthy
for young writers because they're told
if you write something and when you're a
kid and you're like 18 when you're 19 20
21 22 23
you're right anything and because you're
like i'm gonna get published but what
you don't think is you're gonna get
backlash that's gonna be there forever
you're going to get a backlash that
could haunt you for the rest of your
career
and you're told if you don't do this
thing then it isn't going to go in and
you're not going to get paid so you're
like okay i'll write this thing when you
believe it or you don't believe it
because no one likes balance debate or
argument like you say all those
columnists you mentally philips your
david aranovich's none of them are going
here's my thoughts but on the other hand
no one does that of course they don't
they go this is what i believe
and this is and this is and this is one
opinion you know there might be some
balance in it but not really
so you know i think that's a that's a
worry well i mean
if i can take the lead in this
conversation i think there's a real
crisis at the moment uh we're heading
towards a crisis in
in journalism in britain the world but i
can really talk
specifically for great britain because
the american journalism is is a
different model to
to british journalism you know the wall
street journal new york times do
fantastically well
because they did a payable we
we basically the newspaper industry in
the uk
didn't embrace uh online journalism soon
enough
so therefore it's hard it
they're set up so newspapers are set up
so you go against each other
that's just the natural way that they
are they're organized even internally
in the news the world news used to go up
against features all the time
it was it was bonkers we'd be fighting
over the same stories
and outbidding each other on the same
stories and in the in the answer you've
got to stop doing that
so basically all journalism is like
is set up certainly story getting you
know so breaking of stories it's like
it's set up so you you're competing
against everybody else right so
newspapers are by their nature not
collaborative but what it required was
back when the internet was was starting
was
was was becoming clear unfortunately we
had people at the top of newspapers who
were old
and they didn't understand it and they
believed that they would always be
relevant and powerful
now if they've asked a few young people
who are you know younger people who
actually
worked in online what's the future of
this what's going to be
can you come and work with us and show
us what we're doing that would have been
the sensible thing to
do or maybe set up a task force where
they all came together but they didn't
because they don't work like that no you
know they might have something they
might talk but there's no
there's no collective movement where
they go
right we need to do this because if we
don't it's going to lead to this they
just went we're going to be fine
we're fine we're making money we're
going to be fine and they're not fine
and so what you've got is you have some
have a paywall
some that don't i mean they all pretty
much the telegraph actually does and
yeah i think it's the independent does
spectator does but respect
yeah well that's not newspaper yeah but
you know the sun doesn't it tried
for a bit i think did it did try for a
bit and then use the world tribe for a
bit
didn't go didn't you know people weren't
paying for it um
the guardian doesn't there's no
across-the-board thing and as i said to
you earlier you know
once you've not paid for something you
don't want to pay for it in the future
it's hard to make people then
then pay for that so they're struggling
to monetize it
they didn't get online presences for
like 10 years
too late i remember in 2008 when i was
at the people i remember my boss there
saying i was saying when are we gonna
get a website it's 2008
and they said oh it's coming on in
single single-digit weeks i'd left by
the time it happened
it didn't happen and you're like this is
bonkers guys this is so mad
so they were always playing catch-up
because they were full of hubris you
know the bosses they were full of hubris
they were like yeah we're going to be
fine we're we're indestructible we're
the best well we now see they're not and
they're dying
and they were so they were late to get
to getting to that point they don't know
how to monetize it
so what you're seeing is newspapers now
they are slashing staff they are
slashing budgets they're slashing the
pagination
advertising has gone through the floor
because people aren't really buying it
anymore the sales are
dying but they're still struggling to
monetize online but what they want with
online is lots of stories
so basically i used to be able to sell
when i was a freelance journalist i used
to be able to sell stories to some of
the tabloids and some pay better than
others
don't need to say who paid best but you
know i could sell a page lead for
sometimes probably 900 pounds and it
wouldn't be you know wouldn't be a huge
amount
that's great you know you lost like ring
them up got story do you want it yeah
right i didn't have to write it you
write it
and they pay you like 900 pounds maybe
for a spread you might get
a couple of grand for a splash you're
gonna get up to maybe ten thousand
pounds
and what you're sorry just so just to be
clear what you're bringing in is the
information
yeah i mean sometimes i'll write it if
they're busy or whatever but i mean i
did
i mean the ideal situation is you get a
tip and you ring out ring bring someone
up and you say do you want this and they
go yes we do and i go can i leave with
you and they say yes
so all you do is you're passing on a bit
of information and you're getting paid
you know yeah but
sometimes i'll write them i tend not to
have my name on them because
it you know whatever i'm i'm beyond that
i don't need my name on stories anymore
it's irrelevant
and actually to be honest i don't really
sell anyone i'll come on to that why i
don't
so you used to be able to get that for
page leading those papers
now i mean i think there's some papers
you have to get a sign off
on anything over 100 200 quid
really yeah so you know you're thinking
once upon a time i was able to make
one story 900 pounds you know that's a
pretty decent week's wage
you know i mean if you get a couple
you're laughing
now you have to sell five or ten of
those
to make the money and that's in the
paper alone but they're not paying as
much so
it's all being done internally therefore
their stories are less good and
it's just this sort of vicious cycle and
it goes down and down and down
um payments are less pa pagination's
just down and down and down
online some online
places pay for a really good story
they'll pay good money but for a
just a standard online story they might
pay 250
300 quid so you've got to get three of
those
but it's harder to keep them exclusive
because online journalism
it's you know everyone's you know
churning out stuff finding stuff on the
internet
you know churning them out it's harder
to get stuff
and so actually it becomes harder for
freelance journalists and
agencies who have historically provided
an awful lot of stories to newspapers
good quality stories
it's harder for them to make a living so
therefore they leave journalism and they
go into pr
or whatever but a lot of them are going
to pr and they're still
putting in stuff and people like the
newspapers will take pr stuff because
it's free
but it's not journalism is it it's pr
dressed up as a journalistic story but
it's but it's ultimately pr
and so therefore you're getting fewer
journalists working in the industry
you're getting more prs so therefore
it's the rise of pr
and that i don't think is healthy for
british journalism
so if you look at local newspapers have
had this over the last uh
20 years whatever 20 30 years totally
cut to shreds
virtually don't exist and a really good
example of where they failed
was grenfell tower so for ages the
locals have been saying
this is a death trap this place is a
death trap
and had it been 20 years ago there would
have been local journalists
on that patch covering that story
holding the local council's
feet to the fire and saying this is
dangerous you need to change this and
they might have changed it
it didn't happen because they don't
exist anymore it's just if if there even
is a local paper it's one person
who is just doing pressure knocking out
press releases you know so again pr
if you're knocking out pr right or fire
reports or whatever but
they don't have time to do any
investigating they haven't any time to
to go along to your council meetings to
go to your local court hearings
to to find out when someone's behaving
badly and needs to be
needs to be you know that needs to be
highlighted so that was what happened on
local papers
we're starting as you you'll start to
see that on national newspapers
and we also we know what happened at
grandfather you know dozens and dozens
of people died
in this horrific fire and there's been
inquiries that have lasted years people
like why how did this happen
well newspapers used to be able to help
prevent these things from happening they
were important
you know it was an important part of
society
you know an important an important piece
in the jigsaw
of civil of civic society right well it
doesn't exist in locals anymore and
we're starting to see it in national
newspapers now
people like me now i'm not saying i'm
not saying me because i generally
historically i started as a news
reporter but i ended up being a showbiz
writer and i've done sport whatever
i've never been an investigative
journalist i do
do some news stories and some of them
are valuable but i'm not really talking
about me personally but i'm a good
example of this
i can no longer make a living out of
being a freelance journalist
in newspapers it's just not possible
there's too much you require too many
stories for too little money
it's just not i've got a family i've got
a mortgage i've got kids i can't rely on
selling stories
it's happened in the last three or four
years since i went to talk sport i
stopped sending stories come out the
back of it
and it's now not possible the
situation's changed so that means this
you're going to get someone like
me leaving not investigating the story
not chasing down those leads that they
get because they know it's not
worth it financially to to be able to
live a life right
agencies are the same they'll have had
their budgets slashed because newspapers
aren't paying them the same amount of
money that they're used to
so you've got fewer people out there on
patches
looking at stories you know going to
court finding out that someone's been
bad or or whatever
and therefore what will happen is
inevitably it's happening
there's a good example another guy i
spoke to investigate journalist did
stuff for the times
he was in his 60s so it was fine for him
he was able to do these stories but
he used to do these invested stories
which were really in-depth stuff for the
times
and i asked him how much you get paid
for a page lead and he said 350 quid
this was like four three years ago right
he's like 350 quid i was like what so
you have to make
at least two maybe three a week to make
this
you know your weekly wage really and he
probably didn't have a mortgage he was
fine
but there are young people who who won't
be able to do that so it does mean that
people
aren't you know bad people are going to
be able to get away with bad things on a
national level now
whereas before it was it was more local
and i think we're in a real
we're a really worrying point where if
that function of civic society isn't
functioning properly what does that lead
to
that allows people to get away with bad
things be it the government or
you know or any of the public bodies or
the police or
criminals or whatever and that that's a
worry that's a real worry i don't know
how i
you know i can't give you an answer
about what we do
to improve this situation but it is
simple we should all be seriously
worried about that whether you look
whether you
think jonah's a mainstream media or is
not doing its job or not
it did a job it did do a job it reported
bad things it reported on bad people it
held people to account
it got you know it did a lot of a lot of
that stuff and it's
not able to do that anymore i don't
think no certainly in the same way it
used to and that's that should worry us
all
and do you think part of it as well is
uh especially tabloid journalism it
relied on the big scoop like we take the
ryan giggs
incident where you know they he cheated
well he had sex with his brother's wife
and it was all covered up
and everyone's like who was it blah blah
blah all you need to do now is go on
twitter
so this way of funding itself on the
scoop and all the rest of it simply
doesn't exist
some scoops have not necessarily moved
the dial financially i did a story on a
footballer sleeping with sleeping with a
sex worker and it was i'm slightly
ashamed to say the best story i ever did
um
and it cost us like 50 grand yeah i
think you know i don't need to say it
was again it doesn't matter but it cost
us like 50 grand to do the whole story
from start to finish including paying
the the sex worker didn't do anything
for the
for the sales figures not nothing but
what it did was it
showed that that newspaper was a
newspaper that that did deliver scoops
and is worth buying
so it was worth that money you know in
that sort of sense it's sort of a
you know like a pride uh splash but
there are some splashes that do move the
dial like
i remember when they did michael
jackson's death bed at the news as well
they put on 250 000 extra
readers that morning uh when it was
selling like just
around about three million or just under
three million it put on two and a few
thousand so some do move the dial
but i speak to people who work in
newspapers now and they're not getting
ringings anymore
no one's ringing them they just i don't
know why that is
is it because newspapers aren't trusted
is it because they're not really
paying the same sort of money anymore
i think partly there's a lot of it is
is that you can't get people to do stuff
with newspapers anymore because it's a
bit shameful
you know the idea that someone would
sell an interview to a
to a story is is
i mean i know for instance the sun you
know a lot of celebrities a lot of
separatists do
stuff with the sun because they know
that it has a value but a lot of them
won't anymore
for various reasons you know the many
reasons that we all know about over the
years
you know that things have been about a
problem with the sun for they won't do
it anymore so
is it just that people don't want to
deal with newspapers so much anymore and
again that means that those stories
aren't being told
you know whistleblowers aren't coming
they're not ringing up you know they've
seen some terrible stuff happening
uh uh hospital that they work at and
they're like
you know years gone by they'd have rung
up the sun or one of the bigger papers
but now they're not why is that i don't
know well yeah and it's interesting you
mentioned that because we get a lot of
people contacting us
with stories yeah yeah well you should
bring the sun
because they're desperate i mean they're
just waiting uh
they're like
that will go down really well with our
viewers in liverpool won't it yeah yeah
we can resell our stories
[Laughter]
and just sell them a lead how much do
you think uh
part of that undermining of trust and i
think it's such an important point that
you made
which is that i know i've always thought
this about the mainstream media and i
criticized many aspects of what the
mainstream media do now a lot
but i've always thought that
investigative journalism was the one
thing that no one else can do
right francis and i aren't going to do
investigative journalism absolutely not
yeah that just wouldn't work
don't do yourself do ourselves that we
don't
i mean you might be struggling here yeah
yeah but but you know what i mean like
uh
so i i actually have always thought that
the mainstream media
newspapers and other broadcasters et
cetera they have a crucial function in
society which you described
which they're now less able to do and
then you should say i should say that
the journalism is one of the things that
has held up and and you know some of
it's not it's not necessarily
particularly being done by man look at
him rolling back
but it is being done by you know
the times does the time does stuff you
know the bbc does say this but less
the point was it's done less right so
this is my point but
i i think um let me ask you this because
i think part of it may be
the undermining of trust had happened
with the news of the world
with the phone hacking with the leveson
inquirer which unveiled quite a lot of
other wrongdoing
not just phone hacking you know uh my
one of my school teachers was
um i've forgotten his name christopher
jeffries
right right yeah yeah so he's a guy for
people who don't know he was
uh wrongly accused of being a murderer
the newspapers because it was just
before christmas there was nothing else
to write about so every newspaper wrote
about him
like well he looked a bit strange and he
looked very and that was what the
headline was i think it was on the sun
wasn't
the the weird world of mr jefferies oh
something like that it was definitely
weird
yeah but i mean that's not a crime it's
not it's not it's not a reason for
ending up on the front page of this well
i think it should be processed no
uh but but you know what i'm saying is
like there was one thing after another
where i think people
felt like oh this is this dark nefarious
world which i'm sure always was
but that was never really revealed to
the public i think the more
more is coming out regarding the sort of
dark arts that was used
on uh on newspapers over the years
i mean you've seen there was a channel
four documentary recently
that we've seen it but murder in the car
park which featured
the daniel morgan murder it was he was a
private investigator who was murdered
by uh in a car park of a pub who was
apparently just about to blow the lid on
police corruption by ringing
the papers and his business partner has
since
has been he's been a prime suspect for a
long time and he's stood trial and been
you know acquitted et cetera he was part
of he gave interview as part of this
documentary it's a brilliant documentary
you haven't seen
it it's fascinating i mean the sort of
these two the two
main suspects are both interviewed at
length throughout it which is just
really really interesting just as a sort
of just the sort of um
anthropological you know study study i
mean you know just watching it
is fascinating but it's an interesting
topic the world's the uk's most
investigated murder
30 million pounds have been spent
investigating it and they've never
convicted anybody and now i suspect they
probably won't because
you need fresh evidence to do that and i
don't think you're going to get that
from from 33
years ago and which is a crying shame
because it was appalling
but it just it brought up lots of
police corruption and a whole range of
things and i think that a lot of that
stuff so jonathan reese
was the uh and daniel morgan they
owned a company called southern
investigations and they
were one of the early adopters of dark
arts on newspapers
it's alleged um i mean he's been he's
been done for
for i mean he's he's been number various
things so i mean you know we're probably
legally safe to say
to say this but you know there are
receipts that exist
that show that he was delivering stuff
for national newspapers
uh which were questionable he was
wiretapped saying
you know telling a leading reporter at
the daily mirror you know what we're
doing is illegal
so you know this goes back to the mid
90s and through the mid 90s and then
phone
came to pass i mean if you want to talk
about phonak and it's interesting i i've
i've never hacked a phone
but i know how you do it um and i think
that what happened was if
i mean if this is what this is my take
on what happened in the news the world
um i think that there was a
uh an ongoing budgets get cut
they were still massive then but they
were being cut they weren't as much as
they were in the 90s so they're being
cut
there is a um still that sort
of atmosphere where you've got to
deliver a story and i don't care
i don't care how you do it just do it
right so that
then with that combined to the shrinking
budgets
once upon a time i think they probably
didn't hack phones duragur
i think they probably used them as a
last resort of standing up a story right
but what they would do is they would
probably use other methods that were
nefarious and then they might have a
phone at the end
and what they would do is it often pull
phone
they'd pull they'd blag a phone bill so
they'd pretend to be an employee of the
phone company and say can you send me
that person's bill
please and they'd send it celebrity
whatever
and they would see who they were calling
late at night and they would
go who's that number and they turn that
around
and they'd be like oh look those two
celebrities are dating so then they put
a watch on them
because they knew that was happening so
that's illegal to do that they put a
watch on them
which isn't legal but you know the way
they got there was
and then they might hack a phone after
that to know that they've been doing
messages or whatever or to but then with
the
um budgets going down and there's still
that sort of like you must get the story
you must deliver
regardless i think that engendered a
culture whereby we you know the most
important thing is getting the story and
we don't care how
we haven't got huge budgets to do these
watches because they're really expensive
to put a photographer
on a job 24 7 for a week that's really
expensive
all right well and then it started with
journalists going well
let's see if we can find a story by
hacking a phone so that was how i think
that's how the journey
was made and then at that point it
became you know they started
hacking as we as we know people close to
the royalty and that was how the bloom
went up and
you know the news of the world said one
rogue reporter which was later proven
not to be true um and and then there's a
lot coming out about it and i think that
i think there's more to come i mean
prince harry at the moment
is um is suing a couple of newspapers
over phone hacking he believes he's been
surveyed his entire life
phone hacked and um would that surprise
you
i think it's brazen but probably not i
mean
this is the thing is you know when
you've been in it i i know so that's the
thing
i never hacked the phone but one of my
one of my best friends
uh at the news the world one of my
colleagues is sort of a mentor to me a
guy called dan evans
um he was the whistleblower uh who moved
from the sunday mirror to the news of
the world and brought
phone hacking with him from there onto
the features department
and basically my former boss there was
uh got a suspended sentence for
conspiracy to
to hack phones because of his work with
dan evans so dan
i i used to sit next to him but i had no
idea i had no clue what was going on you
know
and i remember saying stuff to me is oh
god you're really good tom you mean a
really good reporter
you know you get some great stories uh
fair play you know like i'm really
impressed by you and i was like
so do you but looking back now i'm like
i bet he was hacking phones
so actually you know he was envious that
that
i was able to generate some stories
without hacking phones but the pressure
was on him he was brought in
on the basis that he was going to do
this so then he had to do it and so
it sort of enveloped his world but from
knowing dan
and and from reading widely around the
topic and and all that sort of thing
no it doesn't surprise me really um it
saddens me
but it doesn't surprise me what saddens
me as well is that
so you know the thing is with
celebrities we sort of you you
i'm not saying that hacking is a
celebrity is okay it's clearly patently
not okay but some people might say well
they're just celebrities right
the thing was they weren't just hacking
celebrities phones you know it was
anyone who came into
um as we as we knew your mini dollar et
cetera et cetera all that sort of stuff
it was anybody that came under the glare
of newspapers anyone who happened to
find themselves
in you know of interest to newspapers
would basically have their lives
ransacked their private
information ransacked phones hacked
whatever
and can you i mean that must have ruined
relationships
it must have ruined mental health uh
ruined
careers lives you know because people
are going you leak that you must delete
that you know and
what an awful thing to have gone through
and that makes me really sad
that makes me sad that that that the
idea that getting this story
was more important than than
people's than other people's lives
you know it was like the story is king
well it's bollocks isn't it and it's
just [ __ ] bollocks
you know no story i mean this is a
public interest
to you know then i'm i'm i'm more
sanguine about it
but just doing it on the basis that you
want you need a story
on the latest you know you need a
newsline on the latest story is just
awful and also what upsets me is that
there are a lot of people who were doing
all this stuff
who've gone on to be incredibly
successful in their industry
and good people who just who who
who did good quality journalism without
having to ruin anyone's life without
having to
turn to illegal or illicit news
gathering
techniques didn't
and that's [ __ ] you know that's
that's real that's a real that's a shame
and actually it comes back to the point
of why sometimes people now
don't trust newspapers anymore because
there are people who are claimed to have
been doing this or known to be
who are still who were promoted and
became the bosses
um yeah so that's that that that that's
slightly frustrates me but you know
whatever it is what it is you know
they're private companies they do what
they want
and actually you know what i should say
as well newspapers isn't the only place
that this goes ahead you know
there's all sorts of illegal activity
that goes on in banking that goes on in
uh law that goes on in whatever but i
don't work in them
so you know what i don't agree with i
think it's wrong but i don't work in
those areas so i don't have the same
passion or upset about that happening
that i feel happened in newspapers which
i
hold very dear to my heart historically
before you jump in front very quickly
there's also another small distinction
there which is we don't expect
the banks or lawyers to hold the
government to account
or to hold powerful to account whereas
the job of journalism
for some journalism is to be
on uh kind of vigilant against
misbehaving
corruption right and i think that's why
there's a double disappointment
sometimes with elements of journalism
where
it's like not only are these people not
necessarily doing the job that we want
them to do but they're also
corrupt themselves while they're they're
criticizing others i think
and also you know there's not many
people um
who have worked in newspapers or
historically who there's a sort of a bit
of an immerser
you know you don't criticize newspapers
and i criticize them on the basis uh hey
i don't work there anymore
yeah but but but more importantly
because it's because i care
you know someone might look at this like
someone i used to work with or whatever
or people i still
you know work with and go oh you
shouldn't be doing this you shouldn't be
saying this stuff i say because i care
i say it because because i'm passionate
about it because it's important to me
that you know because i know what
newspapers can do i know the good that
newspapers can do
i know how important they can be
crucial in fact for a civic society as
we spoke about earlier
and i and i've done things that were
important i've done stories that were
important i've done stories that change
people's lives
and that is the good that they can do
and so to see it
you know see people who who work in it
behaving that way
in that way it upsets me so i say all
this stuff not because i'm
bitter about newspapers it's because i
give a [ __ ]
it doesn't care because it's important
and and i think that
often newspapers or too often newspapers
aren't fulfilling the function
that they should be fulfilling i think
the the moment with phone hacking i'll
be honest with you i don't think people
cared that much about celebrities i
think there is a general attitude about
it
in the uk of like well you put yourself
in the public eye which by the way is
wrong and it's [ __ ] but i do there
is i do believe that is true
yeah so and they feel that way and like
you said it's not right
but i think the moment people got really
angry about the phone hacking scandal
was millie dowler yeah where
her i think and correct me if i'm wrong
tom her mobile phone was missing
and then there were messages from her
parents uh on the phone so i mean her
phone would have been missing because it
was would have been with her but um
it was basically the the the claim that
the guardian made
yeah uh was that
the news of the world hacked the
voicemail which they did
but they also deleted it so they deleted
voicemails
um and that gave the darrella family
false hope
that she was still alive because it was
like oh she's she's listening to her
messages
but she hadn't they were wrong that was
what shut the news the world by the way
that that claim that one claim was was
was ultimately what the straw that broke
the camel's back a rupert murdoch might
close it eventually he might have closed
it it might have been something else if
it wasn't that would have been something
else but they were wrong in that the
guardian
were were mistaken in that they got that
wrong
um the voicemails delete themselves
automatically after a certain amount of
time
and that's what actually happened um but
the guardian ran this and i actually
went on tv
afterwards defending this and saying
actually you know what
the guardian are saying all this stuff
and your whole they're holding
themselves up
as um as a sort of um
paragon of virtue well it's not like the
guardian
you know they're saying you know look if
you're gonna if you're going to
criticize you need to
you need to make sure that you're right
yeah you know if you're going to
criticize
ethics in journalism you need to make
sure that your stories are right and it
wasn't right and i went on and i said
actually i think that that was the
moment
so for me when the news the world shut
i i remember so the week that it
happened the week the news the world
shut
um that story broke
and uh people i was you know just do
showbiz interviews and they started
dropping out they were like i don't want
to do anything with the news world i was
like
i don't know i'm going to do my job here
i was getting loads of grief on twitter
for you know being scum use the world
journalist but there was a dictat that
we weren't able to send in or rather we
weren't getting any guidance over what
we could say so i was just
people were just attacking me on twitter
and i couldn't defend myself and it's
weird to just go oh you know
something else and ignore all that stuff
because
so i just withdrew i also boycotted the
office
along with one of my other colleagues
because i wanted to send a message out
as one of the more senior
reporters at the news the world the tv
editor i was like
you need to tell us what's going on you
need to give us some guidance because
this is unacceptable what
what's happened here is unacceptable and
we're just being left
to hang right and then
and it was that it was the mini data
piece and i'm ringing my dad
who never really liked the fact i worked
for for
for the news of the world for rupert
murdoch he was proud that i was there
but he he didn't
he didn't like it i bring him and i was
in tears i was like i've got to leave
this paper i can't
i i yeah as a just as a personal
thing i i can't stay at a newspaper that
has
that has paid someone else to do this
and made the lot you know
potentially impacted in the criminal
investigation but also
has done this to those poor parents i've
got to leave so i boycotted the office
and so yeah for it to not be true
[Laughter]
but you know what they happen they did
you know they did hack a voicemail
yeah so you know i you know it it's sort
of semantics really it's unforgivable i
mean it's indefensible unforgivable and
all the rest of it
but tom it's been a pleasure chatting
with you man really fascinating stuff
and i think
you're welcome it gives it context to a
lot of the stuff that people feel when
they look at newspapers when they look
at their tv screens when they look at
broadcasting
and they they feel certain things but
they don't necessarily know why
you know and i think the point you made
particularly about
the fact that it's becoming harder and
harder to hold people
to account for things that are going
wrong i think that's so true
well the government right would have
fallen in normal times
the government would have fallen again
and again and again there would have
been resignations all over the place
if if they still had that power
but i don't think they do they have some
power you know they
they they have the ability to i mean
leaving the eu stuff they you know they
exert a lot of power over that but i
don't know
did they lead people to that or did they
reflect people's
view on that but yeah you know look at
the government and the way they're
behaving at the moment it's you know
there are plenty of opportunities where
there would have been people who would
resign in normal situate you know
10 15 years ago but they're not now is
that to do with the media
you know possibly you know people aren't
they're not as powerful they're getting
them
people getting their news from elsewhere
social media et cetera i don't know
brilliant and like i said great
interview and the last question we
always ask is what's the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be well i don't
think we're talking about this enough
actually so
you know i sort of i i you you said i
was going to get asked this question at
the end
and i didn't know an answer but actually
i'm talking about it i think this is
important this is something that we
should be talking about
i'm i'm sick of people actually saying
that journalism is
you know is
the msn is is this or is that it's like
it look it's just part of a wider media
and it all has its value and it all has
its merits
and i think that we need to talk about
this more and we need to work out how
we're going to fund this
because at the moment it isn't going to
fund itself
so if you want if you want a free and
fair media
then you will need something you need
something
to fund it you know like and otherwise
it's going to be
someone that you might not like the
politics of or someone that you think
might not be doing it for the right
reasons
you know rather than just being
campaigning
journalism or you know or exposing
journalism
i think that's what we need to talk
about where's the money coming from for
journalism in this country how are we
gonna
get get over this and what we're going
to do because if we don't
the results are going to be incredibly
worrying
i don't know where it goes i honestly
don't know where it goes but it
it doesn't seem positive i don't see a
positive outcome to it
well on that cherry note
we're gonna wrap up uh tom thank you so
much for coming have you been chased off
twitter uh by those mobs are you still
on there
uh i'm still on there but a little bit
like i can't be bothered to be honest
when i was presenting on talk sport i i
i would just get
so much [ __ ] yeah we both yeah yeah
football fans guys i'm only pretending
to care
i don't care i don't care i remember tom
and i used to co
i used to co-host with you on the
overnight i remember could be
because i said i voted romaine i think
oh someone called me uh
what is it a pro remain pedo apology
something like that yeah get a lot of
that stuff i mean they nailed it but i
got one person texting me once to
say um your brother's a much better
broadcaster than you
which i thought was lovely i was like
well that's cost you 50p so you know
yeah you obviously cared enough to
message me no so i am on twitter
uh but i won't bother giving you my hand
or cause all right don't follow him
don't send him any [ __ ] and i'm sorry
that someone called you a pro romaine
but if you do want to but if you are if
you do want to follow anything
so raw roar the 90s rave podcast
if you've got even a vague interest in
you don't have to be into rave music in
the 90s if you're into dance music if
you're into
culture and british society in the 90s
there will be something in it for you
and i'm hopeful
it's going to be journalistic there's
going to be loads of interesting stories
it's not all just going to be about rave
stuff so
that's my new project if anyone wants to
you know we're on facebook twitter
instagram i've got by the time this is
out i think they'll put the website i'll
be live so it's raw
uh the 90s rave podcast it looks great
man you showed us a few pictures before
we started it looks really cool yeah
we'll see i mean
i can monetize it it's like if i can
come anything close to you guys then
you know i'll be a happy man you do it
very well it might take a few years
no man it'll be great well i'll run out
of subjects but it's only limited to be
honest
but yeah thanks very much for coming on
we'll make sure to put all that stuff in
the description i really appreciate your
time thanks man
cheers tom and i will see you very soon
with another brilliant episode or catch
us on the livestream
absolutely take care and see you soon
guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word